so who's my guest this week is the chief
executive of the international rescue
committee david miliband
nearly 80 million people were forced to
flee their homes last year and that was
before russia invaded ukraine fueling a
growing global food crisis
founded at the request of albert
einstein in the 1930s the international
rescue committee helps resettle and
educate refugees
treading a path between policy politics
populism and people
not always a conducive mix
its president and ceo also knows both
government and non-governmental power as
a former british foreign secretary
from ukraine syria afghanistan and south
sudan to the u.s border and the english
channel how can ngos act in the best
interests of refugees while navigating
governments with competing priorities
here's what's coming up is it
frustrating the lack of awareness and
understanding people have about
displaced people around the world as
well well i think that the scenes from
ukraine they've created everyone that
visceral sense it could be me that's a
fundamental
mind shift for people do you want to get
back into politics i'm running a 1.4
billion ngo we are in the middle of the
largest refugee crisis since the second
world war and i feel genuinely lucky to
be doing this job
david thank you very much for joining me
thank you for having me i thought we'd
start with of course what you focus on
which is displaced people and just
looking at the numbers 80 million
displaced people now ukraine plus a
global food crisis we've hit 100 million
displaced people according to the unrc
this year and i wonder from your vantage
point what are you most concerned about
with those sorts of numbers so i run an
international humanitarian organization
the international rescue committee with
this extraordinary heritage was founded
by albert einstein to rescue people from
europe today
we work in 35 countries that are either
in conflict
so places like somalia or
parts of ethiopia parts of syria or
places that are hosting what you call
rightly the displaced and just to be
absolutely clear these are people who
are forced to flee their homes by
violence and by persecution and by
disaster so we're not talking about
economic migration here we're talking
about people who are victims of of
conflict and disaster
and the places that we're most worried
about are those either that are in the
front line so the east of ukraine is a
classic
example parts of ethiopia today there's
fortunately a ceasefire in yemen so
there's less immediate threat to life
and limb there the afghan conflict is
over
but the places where there isn't a
raging conflict but have recently been
in conflict
there's frankly not just food insecurity
hunger there's the real thread of mass
famine so the horn of africa
the sahel region of africa afghanistan
where 97 of the population it seems
almost incredible but these are official
un figures are living in poverty yemen
17 million people dependent on
the world food program essentially for
for support
i'm worried that literally we're facing
a life and death situation in conflict
zones but also
in places that aren't in conflict but
where they're
the combination of the after effects of
conflict on farming the impact of the
rise in food prices the impact of the
rise in energy prices
means that people are
really on the brink even before you
begin to think about humanitarian help
for health for education for livelihoods
okay because i suppose you're right that
people's minds stay focused at the point
of conflict don't they and then they
don't know very much perhaps about what
happens next and those points well there
are 50 3 53 different civil conflicts
going around the world at the moment 53
yeah and
the the diplomacy doesn't work because
we know diplomacy
as
sorting out relations between states
these are 53 conflicts within states yes
and that's where the displacement is
coming from
these days and in post-conflict
societies
like afghanistan the danger is that
conflict returns
and so we're dealing with a cycle now
that we can identify the problem it's
much harder to get to the solutions but
what we try and do as an ngo is a
non-governmental organization
is focus on helping people survive
recover and gain control of their lives
i mean just on the on what's happened
with ukraine and where attention has
been focused
do you feel what's that like when you're
looking across the whole
picture with your teams around the world
to see how much attention then suddenly
goes elsewhere and there were concerns
and i wanted to get your take on this
that perhaps with ukraine
more sympathy more attention went there
because you know as some put it those
people certainly in the west felt like
they were relatable they were like us
yes i think it's undoubtedly the case
that
a war on the continent of europe brings
out a response
especially among europeans that is
visceral
in a way that is different than if it's
in afghanistan or syria or further
away and i think there are two aspects
of the response to the ukraine crisis
that are very striking one which you
were hinting at
is isn't ukraine better funded
than everywhere else and the short
answer to that is yes is it yes it is
four five six seven times as much per
head
as in syria afghanistan yemen
and i think that it's really important
to try and say that ukraine should set a
standard for the level of help that
people should have if they are the
victims of conflict and are on the run
and that help isn't just financial help
the european union pledged to every
ukrainian three years residency three
years right to work
three years access to education in
schools that's not available to most
refugees in most places now the second
thing that's different
is that in the ukraine crisis refugees
have fled to a rich part of the world
i mean even poland is
not the is one of the poorer countries
in europe but it's rich by global
standards most refugees and displaced
people in the 100 million figure that
has been quoted by the un most of them
are in poor countries not in rich
countries they're more likely to be in
uganda ethiopia lebanon bangladesh than
they are in
poland the uk or the us so it places
strain where there's already strain in a
system yes
and it's also a site of
responsibility that is not being
fulfilled
so essentially the myth
in richer countries that they're bearing
the greatest burden isn't true and the
fact that it's poorer countries that are
being expected to bear this
responsibility is not leading to the
kind of responsibility sharing that
people like me would argue for on that
argument that you make you know beyond i
suppose your funding and where the money
that you get goes and you talk about it
not being handouts trying to be an
empowering view of this
with those facts of the majority of
those people going to poorer countries
what isn't being done that should be
done well
look
three percent of the global humanitarian
budget goes on education but half of the
displaced are children
so sways of displaced people
who are refugees or intern displays are
getting no education at all so is that
about allocating the money better that
already exists in the system
you've got to grow that u.n fund un runs
appeals for
uh countries in crisis and they are 20
funded 25 funded so there's significant
under funding even though the funding
has doubled more or less in the last uh
decade why is there underfunding because
the needs have trebled in the last
decade right essentially the number of
displaced people has troubled
the amount of funding has doubled and it
started from a point that was too low so
education is massively under
invested 60
of maternal deaths in childbirth are in
fragile and conflict states from which
people are fleeing and 45
of kids who die in the first month of
life are in fragile and conflict states
so there's massive health needs that are
not being
met never mind the fact that only three
percent of the world's refugees go home
every year end up going home three
percent three percent so
there aren't sustainable solutions most
refugees are not in camps but those that
are end up spending 10 20 30 years there
even though it was set up as a temporary
camp those that are in urban areas 60 of
refugees are in urban areas they have
the opportunities that exist in urban
areas economic opportunities but also
all the risks of child trafficking and
the rest of it so is that now if you're
talking about especially just because it
all goes back to funding i mean it's not
all that but it helps everything else go
are you then saying particular countries
have to have to put their hand in the
pocket a lot more or are you talking
about
i don't know a completely different way
of doing this and funding it well i
think that there's no question that the
richer countries i mean we're talking in
london the uk's cut is overseas aid
budget despite the fact that needs are
growing and
there's only two or three countries in
the world that meet the un's target the
0.7 of national income for richer
countries should go towards development
aid and that development aid needs
increasingly to be on fragile and
conflict states because now more or less
half of the world's extreme poor are not
in the indias and china's of this world
they're in i mean there are more extreme
poor in nigeria than there are in
india even though the population of
india is four times that of nigeria yeah
and the reason is that conflict
is the great driver of extreme poverty
today when you combine
conflict with covid and with the climate
crisis that's how you get the kind of
storm that pushes people into the
famine conditions that we were talking
about at the beginning of this so if you
if you've got all of the rich countries
to get to that level to the 0.7 i mean
the british government's talked about
restoring that and it was covered and it
was temporary but putting aside if you
like one country if you've got all of
the countries to do that would it would
it tally up well it would tally up in
treating the symptoms but when i tell
you there are 53 conflicts
the only way to really address the root
causes
is to tackle the roots of conflict i
mean the reason people are fleeing
is that conflict is untamed and it's
untamed because
the world doesn't have good diplomatic
tools for tackling conflicts within
states it's got much better
notwithstanding ukraine but is that
because of a world view that sorry to
cut across but because there's this idea
that countries should be left to deal
with their own internal issues there's a
significant part of the issue
is the sovereignty argument that what
goes on within a state is only the
member it's only the business of that
state so if we choose to bomb our own
citizens as some states do if we choose
to
deny aid to ourselves that's only
our business
second part of it though is is in a
weird way the opposite
so our analysis is that sovereignty is
being used as a shield against
accountability by governments but
secondly there's a massive growth in the
number of what are called
internationalized conflicts if you look
at libya or you look at syria or you
look at um even um ethiopia there's
external interference
six 10 12 different countries yemen
12 different countries with a
uh
involved with proxies or other supports
so on the one hand it's the sovereignty
argument used to keep the international
system out to keep u.n officials out on
the other hand
internationalization of conflict is
driving the kind of impunity that we're
seeing that's driving more people to
flee we've got no appetite in some ways
at the same time do we for intervention
i know what you just said about the
outside forces but there's this kind of
thing coming together at the same time
and you've been a foreign secretary for
this country for the uk
and you've you will have seen how it
works at a state level so what how do
you deal with that in a climate of
especially i mean you even see of course
america you know i was talking to john
bolton the uh the former security
adviser to trump on this program only a
few weeks ago and he says
biden is just not doing enough to arm
ukraine you know even at arm's length
there is a concern because it's doing we
don't want to get involved so i know
you're talking about diplomacy as
opposed to arming but there is an
appetite there's a lack of appetite for
getting involved isn't that well i think
there is i think you're right and that
partly explains the weakness of the
multilateral
system but i would argue that if these
problems aren't tackled
you end up with more political
instability the interconnected world
ends up rebounding on you
you have to argue for it you have to win
the political argument but why somebody
why somebody like joe biden not winning
it then he said we're back yes and is he
back well i think he's back in some
aspects of the international system but
in others he's blocked and there are two
blockages one blockage of public opinion
which doesn't want him to be spending
his time on foreign matters second on
something like covid where he promised
leadership congress has denied him
a penny of extra international funding
so he's got one hand tied behind his
back which in a way reflects the
domestic politics look my perspective on
this is that the west is in retreat
for
some reasons which are understandable to
do with domestic pressure
and there's vacuum in a lot of places
that's the vacuum that tempted president
putin to invade
ukraine the vacuum that leaves the syria
situation 10 years on is the alongside
ukraine the biggest refugee crisis there
are two frozen conflicts inside syria
now in the north west and the northeast
where we have teams of people working
but it's not part of that there's no
active diplomatic process to resolve
that and whose fault is that well i
think it's i think the vacuum was
created by western
retreat and the and a range of different
actors have moved in to take the place a
recent policy of the uk's with the
intention to deter people from crossing
the english channel you'll be very
familiar with this to enter the uk
illegally has been to deport them to
rwanda at the time we're talking no one
has been because lawyers got involved
and there were human rights issues and
challenges that have been successful so
far
if you look at the polling on it so far
it is not an insignificant number of
people who support it i'm not saying
it's not the majority who do support it
but it's not insignificant
what do you say to those people who
support that who think that is the
solution for people stopping people from
making a very dangerous journey well one
they've been told that the processing of
the asylum claim will be done in rwanda
that's not true your word they are
deported to rwanda is actually true
because even if they pass the asylum
claim they have to stay in rwanda
secondly it's not true to say that
there's no alternative to deporting
people to rwanda if you want to manage
asylum flows other countries show how
you manage the silent flows by running
an effective asylum system thirdly
having left the european union britain
has lost the right to send back to the
continent of europe people who fail
their asylum claim which we had when we
were members of the european union
no british asylum policy can work unless
it works with france it stands to reason
because geography hasn't been ended by
our departure from the european union so
there are alternatives to this policy
that's what i would say
to the to the people who who are tempted
by this policy you can also sound like
you feel like they've been lied to that
there's no question that they've been so
it was missold it was avowedly missiled
as external processing of asylum claims
rather than actually the deportation of
asylum seek because whether or not they
pass them but for those who who want
something to deter so so rather than i
know what you're talking about the
alternatives but they think that
something to stop people getting in
those dingies in the first place because
they've reached france they've reached
safety
compared to whether that's interesting
what would you say to that i'd say to
them did you know
that the policy says there will be no
deportation of children and pregnant
women so there is an incentive for every
people smuggler to say to a pregnant
woman or to a child we'll get you across
it's incentivizing the people smuggling
of unaccompanied children rather than
disincentivizing it and i've also can
trade polls of 77 80 of british people
who say that if people have a legitimate
reason to fear going back to their own
country they should be given refuge
in this country so in the end it's not
about trading and also just because of
the people who come you know the
majority do get the right to stay well
that's a very good point 70 80 90
depending whether they're from syria or
afghanistan or yemen
pass the asylum test that threshold even
without those routes that are that
you're talking about which could be an
alternative to set up a proper process
so they don't have to come in that way
or feel that they have to come
i suppose it's just other countries are
also considering this denmark's looking
at it rwanda obviously in the government
not the opposition they're saying we're
a great country come i mean there's this
idea there's an uncomfortableness around
many parts of this but why are other
countries also looking at it well
because they're looking at the numbers
and they're
seeing that there might be some
political advantage in trying to sell
the idea that this is a quote-unquote
deterrent as i've tried to explain it's
not a deterrent so the deterrent that
won't work is your point so we need to
do something else we know it won't work
because we've seen it in other places
the push factors
that are driving people out of countries
like afghanistan yemen et cetera are so
strong
that
that aspect of the deterrence is not
going to work what i think does
uh behoove really serious attention is
that at the moment there isn't a legal
route to claim asylum if you're at the
moment in afghanistan which i think a
lot of people don't know
you know as a fact about the uk for
instance yes that they will not
necessarily know that there is a
i suppose from your perspective is it is
it frustrating the lack of awareness and
understanding people have about
displaced people around the world as
well well i think that the scenes from
ukraine for all that they can be
criticized as being
giving greater attention than for
refugees from other places they've
created everyone that visceral sense it
could be me you pack your bag you say
goodbye to your husband or your brother
or your
father who's going off to
fight and you leave
that's a
fundamental mind shift for people so
ukraine may have woken people back up i
think it has woken people up you we know
that from the number of people who are
volunteering to have ukrainians come and
stay in their house we know that from
donations to charities we know that from
the
overall public opinion service but what
we know also know is that if countries
don't step up together
then resentment breathes people say well
if people in germany said well we've
taken a million syrians what did france
do not very much
by comparison so you've got to step up
together do you want to get back into
politics i'm running a 1.4 billion ngo
we are in the middle of the largest
refugee crisis since the second world
war and i feel genuinely lucky to be
doing this job i was in politics i'm an
ex-politician all sorts of things can
happen to you after you leave politics
i've found something that allows me to
put my values into
action i feel inspired by the way in
which we've made solutions not suffering
the calling card of the international
rescue community we've grown from being
a 400 million organization to being a
1.4 billion organization and we've got
to take the lessons of our solutions to
health and to hunger and to lack of
education and take them to a wider
audience i always say to people
that i don't
know what i'm gonna do
next
and that's may not be a satisfying
answer but it's a it's an honest answer
you will be still a keen watcher of uk
politics i'd be remiss if i didn't ask
you about are you still a member of the
labour party of the left
kierstama sir stammer the leader of the
labour party there are people who are
very frustrated by his leadership when
there have been what they would say open
goals on the prime minister of the uk uh
boris johnson with issues around him
being fined by the police
through to other trust issues do you
share those frustrations i am as a
british citizen i am much more
frustrated by the policies of the
british government than i am by the
performance of the labour opposition the
country faces massive challenges yes
post austerity post brexit post covid
post the war in ukraine and all that's
done to energy prices and it's not being
given answers by the right in politics
it needs to be given some answers by the
center left in
politics and the judgment in the end has
got to be how is it going to change the
country we're 25 years since the 97
labour election victory which i was
involved with
21 years since the 2001
17 years since 2005 the three elections
that we won on the trot we won on the
trot by presenting a clear project to
the country where agree with or disagree
with it you knew what it was about and
then there were policies to
emblemize and to symbolize the change
that was uh being promised that is the
task
that kiestama has said that he has do
you think we'll have a prime minister
stammer yes i think there's a real
chance of that i think he's i think he's
got
depth and breadth that is important and
anyone who tells you yeah it's certain
it's 100
chance that
that's not the real world that's
that's that's partisanship not uh not
prediction but i think i think he's a
serious person with a real understanding
of how to lead
and
a real sense of where the country's
going wrong and he's got to bring that
out and take it to the british people
has he asked for your advice
he's got tons of advisors your brother's
in the shadow cabinets he's got tons of
advisors doesn't he you know i i i'm
sure he's watching this program and
coming but we'll make sure we'll make
sure no no but when people have been
through things they can reach out to
others who who have been through them
and i was also just wanted to bring up
before our time was over that you took
hillary clinton for a fish and chip
dinner i believe more than one chip i
can report good many chips and chips
does she have vinegar she she in the
great vinegar versus no vinegar divide
she took vinegar she also took tartar
sauce and she also ate mushy peas
without confusing them with avocado
puree which for those of you who are
those of your viewers who are following
followers acute followers of british
politics will know that it's a very
significant uh this was in south shield
which is my former constitution your
former political home and um you've
taken quite a few world leaders and and
dignitaries around that place and you
always go to the same fish and chips
correct sustainable sustainable
coleman's fish and ship shop on the
ocean road okay and so it sounds like
she enjoyed it but i wonder as as two
former politicians have you have you
discussed
you know life beyond and what it's like
to to be out of it now have you seen yes
yes of course and look she did me a
great honor in coming to
south shields which is an x mining
shipbuilding constituency in the
northeast of england where
i i felt embraced by the local community
and
determined to to repay in all sorts of
ways but one way was continuing the
tradition of this south shields lecture
and
you know she's got a extraordinary story
to tell really after 50 years in
public life of some kind or another does
she want you to get back into politics
she's not uh
she's not uh
she'll be an interesting agent for you
asian i don't i would never put it that
way she's a friend
well thank you very much for talking to
us and thank you so much for being with
us until we meet again take care and
goodbye
[Music]